here's what we're going to do new topic
right an interesting thing about all the
extension two points is that they each
have a connection to what you've been
learning in to you doing an extension
one I think is really important every
time you have a look at of a topic to me
okay how does this relate to the rest
I'm very aware of the fact that you guys
are like because you're learning all of
your maths all together whereas I'd like
oh I teach the to your class here then I
teach you an extension cost you etc you
know you kind of have everything all in
one sort of pile I'm so classic job of
this is that on in yeah you're 11
actually whenever they've had task
recently and the extension students are
using a tea result method for a to your
question there's no nothing wrong with
that however of course if you get
something wrong it's kinda like well I'm
used the wrong approach to this and
never bled yourself no problems the tune
is to never needs to worry about and
that's probably because it's like I
don't really have a normal to you and
what's extension one now you may recall
even though we still call this the
courses used to be called this and they
were good and bad things about that I
know my brother who went through um for
unit Matthews back in the day he was
very sad what it's like no more fighting
about this Messiah era is over the
reason why they did this is because
there was an emphasis where there was
this change to say look she threw you
data for you right now not just more of
the same they're not just like are you
you to the people you do some mats and
your three it you just do more of it
like there's more stuff to discover but
it's the same difficulty in changing
their names to extension one in
extension to what this bodice place is
trying to say is look these are not just
more stuff this is qualitatively more
difficult stuff right so that's what
makes it extension so I thought I would
take the courses sorry the topics that
we'd be through and live through what's
the relationship between two to three
the stuff to extension one stuff I
should tell you
add extension to now has taken me years
to try and wrap my head around this and
we kind of far enough into the course
that in fact I'm not just going to do
the topics that you have already done
I'm actually going to give you a little
bit of teaser of what's what's ahead
okay I'm usually pretty against spoilers
but when I looked at what I could
potentially be spoiling like that I
think I feel comfortable games so don't
feel like you need to write this doing
except there may be the last column of
this three column table this is half of
it so here's what we've done so far in
extension to right now what the way you
can see I've arranged it is we've got
all these two unit and extension 1
topics and these ones feed into an
extension to topic yeah oh then I want
to talk about what's the almost
different now some of this you already
know because we've looked at these
topics already complex numbers is where
we kicked off right which is it hugely
fun topic partly because it brings
together these huge massive you know
sort of building blocks into your head
extension work and from k to 10 honestly
so it's kind of the culmination of so
much in mathematics real functions high
geometry tree Demetric functions they're
all of the big branches of that mates
will be focusing on with the exception
of calculus and that's because I
calculus with our complex functions is
actually a whole new thing which I hope
some of you guys get to discover at uni
it's actually given it so it's such a
new thing it gets given a new name to
cook analysis sorry that's that's the
the parts of bats in tunics that you end
up leading into complex elders and the
idea that was different was well let's
just think about the idea that the
number doesn't just exist on a lie but
it exists on a plane right there for you
can think about winning as a set a
number has a set of coordinates it's got
two parts to it you can think of a
number is a vector because if not just
has a quantity a scalar quantity but you
can think about this having a direction
as well so that was what was new what
was different from this over this all of
these well we say real functions what we
meet is what de Mitchell numbers at all
of the ways you can put them into a
function get these out okay excuse me
then we look to graphs our grass is one
of the
one of the most sort of like flowing you
like some people don't really see a
distinction between these two we took
everything we do about functions we took
our descended calculation it points to
the behavior of a graph and then we
would put them together we combine them
in lot several ways and we transformed
in your interesting what it's like not
just shifting and that Kofi you're not
just stretching by target so Erin graphs
QB taking the square root reciprocal
whatever and then we can into this year
and we kicked off the year good boy with
colleagues now I think you guys know
this is where quad xscape from right all
the conic sections we actually have
looked at as to the head extension on
students we just didn't know that there
were quite exceptions so the big view
idea was that all of these we call an
algebraic curse because their curves
that are that their expressions are
equations are all come up through
through algebraic means as a person Lord
sign those kinds of functions that's not
algebra we be multiplication addition
subtraction powers etc but they're all
related in this incredible way through
this double cone structure and that was
really cool that was quite amazing and
then we dug into all the implications of
that especially with parametric subpart
honestly uh now the last extension
turtles last the second last extension
to topic that we did course polynomials
which unsurprisingly leads on from the
tutor extension one topic called
polynomial ah but what we dug into if
you recall we looked at the fundamental
theorem of algebra right we looked at
there for a multiplicity of roots and
that's like starting you already knew
that was kind of digging deeper into
what a polynomial ears and then we sort
of also went past where we now we know
what complex numbers are so we can do
with polynomials in the complex field
and we looked at partial fractions which
came out of pollen over your identities
why do we do that again partial
fractions to help with the next topic
right so now I can argue too far so now
this was our last one again
unsurprisingly extension to integration
follows from to unit extension while
integration ah the real characteristic
of that topic was if we have all of
these like you tools right that that
allows us it opens up all these
or difficult integrators that we can
deal with right so we call them sort of
advanced techniques substitutions like
the T results you've met the T results
before but we've never really used it
recruiting staff integration there are
some really hard substitutions you
didn't get given the substitution most
of the time you just have to work it up
and of course the duration by parts that
gave your recurrence relations etc so
paul t Hat's this is where it starts to
get a bit bored you okay now do you
remember how up here in complex numbers
we had this idea of numbers being when
we add a dimension it's not bit ok
that's from tunic scheduler to extension
to you get exactly the same pattern
kinda when you move into mechanics which
is just another word for extension to
motion the kinds of measuring a little
bit under here are mainly beautiful
circular motion motion on a banked track
when you're like going around a curve as
opposed to straight-line motion things
moving up down or left right simple
harmonic motion which is still straight
line but moving in a predictable
oscillating way and then projectile
motion which finally adds in a
two-dimensional sort of bottle it's up
down but it'd go left right as well
while mechanic stars just like complex
numbers is to say well let's add another
dimension to this and let's see what
happens right so circular motion is it
three dimensions you've got all these
different axes of motion the axes that
we used to excuse your daily life now
harder extension one you won't I kind of
been touching on a little bit because
you were you notice we would have dealt
with this under induction when we did it
as extension one topic I just kind of
snuck a bit you didn't tell you their
extension to we haven't touched the
second geometry yet but again same idea
we're going to go further okay we want
to take all of these things together by
the way I actually like to call the part
of proof rather than harder extension
one even though that's what the topic is
called because you have a look at all
those things on the left they are all
about the nature and the rigor of proof
right mathematical proof we said this
other reduction is unlike any other kind
of proof in human endeavor right
scientific proof historical proof they
have places but they are not sure like
mathematical
provements ok so that's seven out of
eight topics including some ones which
we haven't really done yet so that
leaves us with today's topic now in what
or the next couple weeks what makes
extension two volumes accenture to mode
okay now before I show you I just want
to sort of rewind a little bit and i
want you to see just over here if you
sort of take a broad overview right
there's kind of two themes that come up
again and again and again as you move
from two decks that your blood stuff to
extension to hear the two things number
one we dig deeper into the nature of
what things are so paulo vocals was a
perfect example of that right the
fundamental theorem of algebra is
something which actually animates a lot
of what you learn in to you is that you
want like when we're doing quadratics
and you talk about the discriminant we
talk about positive definite definite
etc all of that is try to deal with
we're just supposed to have two grits in
a quadratic that's what the fundamental
theorem of algebra is all about all that
stuff without you know alpha and beta
and the relationships between roots and
coefficients we would want to understand
more deeply like there are there are
things below the surface which we didn't
sort of understand it's to the extension
one students but we kind of lifted the
veil a little bit and so hey there's
more stuff underneath you that was the
first thing that extension two topics do
routinely the second thing is we go up
right we look and we say well what else
is out there right what are the new
kinds of things or arm what kinds of
harder things right I going on where
else can we take these these skills
where can we sort of more off to right
so this is kind of downward movement and
this upward movement um so I should have
mentioned the conex topic is another
good example of going deeper look all
these create curves are related you
never knew they were related but they
were all now what I love about volumes
which I think sometimes it's a bad
reputation it's a great topic I really
love it what I'm about volumes is it
does both of those things it does both
of those things it goes down it goes
deeper and leaves the veil on ideas that
were already
we haven't looked at in detail and on
the basis of that right going back to
first principles which is you think
might be going backwards you actually
open up all these new kinds of volumes
you can look at we're going to revise
what we can do intuitive volumes I will
say there is actually no such thing as
extension one volumes there's no volumes
content that's specific to the extension
one course so we're going to look again
or what we know from to your values but
there are only a very very small number
of long as we can handle with those
techniques right so if we dig deeper
into what's really going on there are
all kinds of weird illiteracy shady we
can look at okay so I hope that gives
you a bit of her like this is what the
character this is what makes it it's not
for unit its extension to you're doing
something different over here okay